masken pflicht in der innenstadt
strengere regeln bei feiern mehrere
bundesländer verschärfen ihre corona
maßnahmen geld für die opfer von
missbrauch die katholische kirche will
bis zu 50.000 euro an betroffene zahl
und nach den verheerenden waldbränden
kalifornien will autos mit
verbrennungsmotoren verbieten
[Musik]
nachrichten nicht da das heute mit
christian sievers abend hinein und
herzlich willkommen bei uns an diesem
donnerstag hat ja stresow guckt nachher
in der sendung auf den sport der herbst
ist da das virus auch immer noch und es
breitet sich wieder schneller aus
besonders bei unseren nachbarn in europa
aber auch in einigen regionen bei uns
das robert koch institut meldet für
deutschland heute 2143 neuinfektionen
zum dritten mal in diesem monat sind es
mehr als 2000 und auch der aktuelle 7
tagesschnitt zeigt stabil hohe zahlen
danach haben sich täglich 1740 menschen
mit dem virus angesteckt und an manchen
orten werden die regeln verschärft
masken pflicht in der münchner altstadt
und beschränkungen für feiern in
nordrhein-westfalen tadeusz parade mit
mehr die stadt haben derzeit
deutschlands größter corona hotspot
greift mit strengen kontakt
beschränkungen durch maximal fünf
personen im öffentlichen raum oder
alternativ zwei haushalte auslöser für
den rasanten anstieg eine türkische
große hochzeit
ansonsten habe ich heute auch schon
angekündigt dass wir bei allen größeren
hochzeiten egal ob deutsch türkisch
bosnisch russisch auftauchen werden mit
dem kommunalen ordnungsdienst und auch
überprüfen ob die angegebene
teilnehmerzahl eingehalten wird die
kontakt beschränkungen gelten zunächst
für zwei wochen
also ich gerade auch
gehört zur risikogruppe zum beispiel
durch mein asthma nicht nur an auch
weitere städte in nrw könnten bald die
kritische marke von über 50
neuinfektionen pro 100000 einwohner
erreichen
privat feiern müssen künftig zwei wochen
vorab mit gästeliste beantragt werden so
die nrw landesregierung zudem seien
punktuelle maßnahmen möglich das ist ja
genau unsere strategie nicht mehr lebt
bei uns für ganze teile von
nordrhein-westfalen sondern dann
konzentriert da wo das problem ist und
dann glaube ich auch dass in wenigen
zahlen die zahlen zurückgehen
und dass man dann die maßnahmen wieder
lockern kann deutschlandweit entwickeln
sich immer mehr regionen zu corona
hotspots neben hahn hat auch der
landkreis dingolfing landau in bayern
die kritische 50er marke gerissen die
infektionen waren bei einem
logistikdienstleister festgestellt
worden
testergebnisse von mehreren hundert
mitarbeitern auf dem gelände stehen noch
aus auch in münchen ziehen die behörden
angesichts rasant steigender corona
neuinfektionen die zügel an
ob viktualienmarkt oder marienplatz in
der altstadt gilt seit heute vormittag
auch unter freiem himmel
masken pflicht um uns herum in europa
wird die lage insbesondere für urlauber
kurz vor den herbstferien
unübersichtlich um es vorsichtig
auszudrücken
mehr als die hälfte der eu staaten hat
die bundesregierung zumindest teilweise
zu risikogebieten erklärt und sie warnt
vor reisen dorthin
die reisewarnung ist kein verbot soll
aber abschreckend wirken jürgen kehl hat
die details kofferraum packen mal
spontan ins ausland fahren gar nicht so
einfach in corona zeiten dänemark wäre
vielleicht ganz schön aber die region um
die hauptstadt kopenhagen ist nun
risikogebiet auch im goldenen prag warnt
das auswärtige amt verhörte
ansteckungsgefahr
nun ist bis auf zwei regionen ganz
tschechien betroffen
schon länger auf der warnliste dienen
jetzt ist auch vorarlberg dazugekommen
für ganz österreich schon beschlossen
das aus für après ski in frankreich ist
die korona lage insgesamt sehr kritisch
paris auch ein zentrum der ansteckung
jetzt zusätzlich auf der warnliste unter
anderem die britannia und dinamo die
dann vielleicht mit dem flieger etwas
weiter weg italien ist eine option nicht
zu spanien
das ganze land bleibt risikogebiet neue
jetzt die warnung für portugals
metropole lissabon und auch vor reisen
in die region um die irische hauptstadt
dublin wird abgeraten
wer es dennoch wagt muss wissen bei der
rückkehr wird ein corona test und
quarantäne fällig bis ein negatives
testergebnis vorliegt deutschland
eingekreist von risikogebieten nur zwei
unsere nachbarn sind nicht auf der
warnliste polen und luxemburg
welche regionen genau die
bundesregierung als crooner
risikogebiete deklariert hat und was
daraus folgt dazu geben wir ihnen einen
überblick zum nachlesen in der zdf-
heute nochmal deutlich brisanter ist die
situation im moment in israel das land
verzeichnet immer mehr corona fälle
die regierung hat schon einen zweiten
lockdown verhängt und der wird jetzt
noch einmal verschärft dazu kommt eine
aufgewühlte politische lage mit
protesten gegen regierungschef benjamin
netanjahu
auch die sollen jetzt verboten werden
was tel aviv michael bewerbung gebaut
für den krieg in betrieb aber erst im
kampf gegen korona im untergrund
hospital in der bunker mäßig ausgebauten
tiefgarage der uniklinik rambam in haifa
werden 2.000 betten hergerichtet die
regulären kapazitäten sind erschöpft die
intensivstation ist voll ab heute werden
alle cupid 19 patienten in den bunker
gebracht das hätten selbst die
kampferprobten israelis nie gedacht
wir dachten damals an eine militärische
konfrontation aber jetzt sehen wir dass
diese einrichtung genauso für andere
szenarios taugt zum beispiel für eine
pandemie
wir reden inzwischen von 200 250
einlieferung mit corona pro tag in die
kliniken israels darauf müssen wir
vorbereitet sein
inzwischen häufen sich die schweren
fälle bei fast 7000 neuinfektionen
täglich stößt auch die klinik in kfar
saba weiter im süden an ihre grenze das
problem sei nicht fehlende technik sagt
dr king sondern fehlendes personal das
müsse er aus anderen abteilungen
abziehen
meine hauptsorge ist dass ich in eine
situation kommen in der ich die
hereinkommen den patienten nicht mehr
versorgen kann
das müssen wir vermeiden
kurz nach dem zweiten lockdown
verschärft die regierung nun erneut die
regeln das öffentliche leben wird fast
ganz heruntergefahren
umstritten ist nicht nur die geplante
einschränkung von demonstrationen die
sich besonders gegen ministerpräsidentin
tanja berichten in der kritik auch das
weitere einschnüren der wirtschaft ich
finde den locker und gar nicht gut er
wird das land ruinieren
es muss doch mal einen knall geben auch
wenn der lockdown hart wird diese
ansteckungszahlen richten uns zu und am
sonntag beginnt in israel jom kippur für
viele im land wird es ein einsamer
feiertag werden so viele dieser sendung
zum thema corona jetzt eine meldung aus
berlin die viele überrascht hat der chef
des militärgeheimdienstes mhd christoph
gramm muss gehen
das hat verteidigungsministerin annegret
kramp karrenbauer entschieden
der mhd hat im kampf gegen
rechtsextremismus in der bundeswehr eine
wichtige rolle
zuletzt hatte es mehrere rechtsextreme
vorfälle gegeben etwa bei der
elitetruppe ksk und dazu noch eine frage
an chuck und alaa banerjee in berlin
guten grund warum muss der mb-chef gehen
also die offizielle erklärung lautet
weil jetzt ein neuer abschnitt in der
laufenden reform des mhd ansteht und da
steht in der pressemitteilung
das wolle man auch personell sichtbar
machen das steht aber auch zusätzlich
noch es seien zusätzliche anstrengungen
und dynamik in diesem neuen abschnitt
erforderlich und das lässt darauf
schließen dass der bisherige amtsinhaber
diese dynamik geben und diese
anstrengungen nicht in ausreichendem
maße geliefert hat das hören wir auch
aus parlamentskreisen dort gab es schon
länger den eindruck dass die
bundesverteidigungsministerium annegret
kramp karrenbauer mit den aktivitäten es
immer die im kampf gegen extremismus bei
der bundeswehr
alles andere als zufrieden gewesen ist
da gab es verschiedene pannen unter
anderem das weiterreichen von geheim
durchsuchungs fotos und es gab auch
enttäuschungen denn je mehr auch
aufgedeckt wurde desto mehr stellt sich
auch die frage warum ist das bisher
eigentlich nicht aufgefallen auch unter
dem amtierenden präsidenten des mrd und
das alles gemeinsam wird wahrscheinlich
dazu geführt haben dass jetzt diese
person
eine entscheidung getroffen wurde vielen
dank für diese hintergründe heute abend
auf den früheren vw konzernchef martin
winterkorn kommt wegen des diesel
skandals ein weiterer prozess zu dass er
wegen betrugs auf die anklagebank muss
stand schon fest jetzt kommt ein
verfahren wegen des verdachts auf
marktmanipulation dazu das
braunschweiger landgericht hat die
anklage zugelassen danach soll
winterkorn die finanzmärkte zu spät
informiert haben über die finanziellen
risiken für den konzern nach dem
auffliegen der abgas manipulation
bezahlbares wohnen der dauerbrenner in
deutschland in weimar beraten derzeit
die bauminister der länder über neue
konzepte
denn es gibt in deutschland zu wenige
sozialwohnungen wie nie zuvor in den
vergangenen 16 jahren hat sich ihre zahl
fast halbiert ende 2009 10 gab es in
deutschland gerade noch 1,14 millionen
sozialwohnungen und die tendenz weiter
fallend
besorgniserregend ist auch der trend auf
dem allgemeinen wohnungsmarkt dort
steigen die mieten und kaufpreise weiter
an
florian kojak jetzt über nöte und
alternativen die raw 70 in weimar einst
klinikum der stadt heute
genossenschaftliches wohnprojekt die
idee dahinter gemeinschaftlichen
bezahlbaren wohnraum schaffen ohne
renditeorientiert das interesse stefan
hempel ist gründungsmitglied hat bei der
sanierung geholfen
vor anderthalb jahren ist er mit seiner
familie eingezogen erstbezug einer
wohnung die sie sich sonst in weimar
nicht hätten leisten können durch die
mieten explosion die wir hier in den
letzten jahren erlebt haben und jetzt
auch mit dem zweiten kind war es einfach
nicht möglich da eine größere wohnung zu
finden die wir bezahlen können
bezahlbares wohnen in vielen deutschen
städten ein immer größer werdendes
problem und nun auch eines der themen
auf der bauministerkonferenz der länder
wir brauchen vor allem mehr wohnungsbau
und das bedeutet dass der bund die
finanziellen zusagen die er den ländern
für den wohnungsbau gibt nicht nur auf
dem heutigen niveau halten muss und zwar
langfristig halten muss sondern auch
steigern muss ein problem was aktuell an
neuen sozialwohnungen entsteht
vielleicht nicht aus was an alten
wegfällt
denn wenn die aus der preisbindung
fallen können sie teurer weitervermietet
werden
es wird gebaut jedoch am bedarf vorbei
es gibt immer mehr menschen die weniger
geld zur verfügung haben bei steigenden
preisen die nachfrage ist da gerade in
den ballungszentren und genau hier
brauchen wir eben bezahlbaren wohnraum
der nicht vorhanden ist
in der u17 haben sie ihn sich selbst
geschaffen und zwar langfristig wie
stefan hempl sagt ihnen können hier
niemand die mietpreise diktieren und so
könnten sie sich ihre wohnung auch noch
in 30 jahren leisten bis zu 50.000 euro
so viel will die katholische kirche
menschen zahlen die von priestern
sexuell missbraucht wurden
die opfer müssen einen antrag stellen
dann soll eine unabhängige kommission
entscheiden
so haben es die deutschen bischöfe heute
beschlossen das reicht nicht finden
vertreter der opfer sie kritisieren
sowohl die höhe der zahlungen als auch
das verfahren stefan schlosser mit den
details mittlerweile ist es über zehn
jahre her dass die enthüllungen am
berliner canisius-kolleg den
missbrauchsskandal in der katholischen
kirche ins rollen gebracht haben erst
jetzt konnten sich die deutschen
bischöfe auf anerkennungs leistungen für
die opfer einigen angelehnt an
schmerzensgeldzahlungen staatlicher
gerichte wir orientieren uns dabei an
den höheren gerichtlichen entscheidungen
das bedeutet dass wir auch in der
verfahrensordnung den referenzpunkt des
oberen bereich von leistungen in
vergleichbaren fällen ansetzen und damit
einen preisrahmen bis zu 50.000 euro
setzen werden
dieser rahmen soll in allen 27 diözesen
einheitlich gelten ein unabhängiges
gremium wird über die höhe der
auszahlungen in jedem einzelfall
entscheiden
januar 2021 soll das verfahren starten
dann können betroffene anträge stellen
im vergangenen jahr standen noch summen
bis zu 400.000 euro zur debatte
für matthias katsch selbst opfer von
missbrauch im canisius-kolleg und nun
vertreter von betroffenen ist die summe
viel zu gering
wir können das ja nur beklagen wir haben
ja keine macht etwas anderes zu
erzwingen
und deswegen braucht dass das eingreifen
von politik von parlament zu sagen wir
bringen diese interessen an einen tisch
und wir sorgen für einen ausgleich
die bischöfe hoffen darauf das thema
missbrauch in der kirche befrieden zu
können doch die betroffenen werden keine
ruhe geben ins ausland in hongkong ist
der prominente regierungskritiker joshua
wohnung ein weiteres mal festgenommen
worden
wenig später kam er auf kaution frei
anlass der festnahme war eine unerlaubte
demonstration vor rund einem jahr an der
wahl teilgenommen hatte er selbst zeigte
sich heute unbeeindruckt und kündigte an
sich weiter zur wehr zu setzen dagegen
dass in hongkong demokratische
freiheiten beschnitten werden ulf röller
ist unser korrespondent in peking
genannt wie groß sind denn die chancen
der demokratiebewegung in hongkong dass
sie überhaupt noch etwas erreichen kann
eigentlich glaube ich nicht dass die
demokratiebewegung wirklich noch eine
chance hat etwas zu erreichen
es hat in den letzten wochen immer
wieder den versuch gegeben groß
demonstrationen zu organisieren
aber die massen kamen nicht die menschen
haben angst sie haben angst vor
festnahmen und verhaften
außerdem geht die polizei jetzt sehr
gezielt gegen die führenden köpfe der
demokratiebewegung vor sowie joshua den
letzten wochen viele festgenommen worden
es gab eine verhaftungswelle und es
kommt noch dazu dass der große
internationale aufschrei den doch vielen
hongkongs gehofft haben dass es ihn gibt
nicht ganz so stark gewesen ist die
meisten länder wollen sich eben nicht
mit china anlegen china ist sehr sehr
wichtig wichtig da gibt es viele
abhängigkeiten und so muss man wohl
sagen dass nach einem jahr was vor allem
jahr losgehen mit der hoffnung auf
freiheit und unabhängigkeit eigentlich
jetzt zu ende geht
vielen dank ulf röller zdf peking unser
nächstes thema kalifornien hat das aus
für alle autos mit benzin- oder
dieselmotoren angekündigt der us
bundesstaat will somit helfen den
klimawandel zu bekämpfen denn es brennt
auf einer gigantischen fläche für die
massive trockenheit in der region ist
die erderwärmung mit verantwortlich da
sind sich die meisten wissenschaftler
einig kalifornien will jetzt
gegensteuern
ab 2035 sollen dort nur noch
emissionsfreie autos verkauft werden
volker check zu den auswirkungen auch
auf die deutschen autofirmen
kaliforniens gouverneur news umgeht
werbewirksam in die offensive auf der
motorhaube eines amerikanischen
sportwagens unter schreibt die
verordnung die ein ende von diesel und
benzin fahrzeugen ein deuten soll in 15
jahren beenden wir den verkauf von
verbrennungsmotoren werden wir unsere
ehrgeizigen ziele bis zum jahr 2045 ganz
auf emissionen zu verzichten
niemals erreichen deutsche hersteller
werden das angekündigte aus für diesel
und super sicher genau beobachten denn
auch sie wollen in den usa weiter
fahrzeuge verkaufen vom verband der
autoindustrie gibt es heute nur einen
satz von präsidentin hildegard müller
die pariser klimaschutzziele zu denen
die deutsche automobilindustrie ohne
abstriche steht erreichen wir am besten
durch technologieoffenheit staatliche
verbote die den innovationsgeist
beschränken sind nicht zielführend
innovations- und mobilitäts experten
glauben dass kalifornien für die
autoindustrie weltweit zum schrittmacher
werden könnte kalifornien ist eben nicht
nur die regulierung sondern ich finde
auch wirklich sehr spannend ist
natürlich die innovationskraft delikten
vale oder die kapitalkraft die
kalifornien generell hat und diese
sachen zusammen glaube ich werden
wegweisend sein
die konkurrenz ist auf dem sprung die
deutsche autoindustrie weiß jetzt in 15
jahren ist die autowelt zumindestens in
kalifornien elektrisch und jetzt noch
das in der sendung was sich vor der
küste der australischen insel tasmanien
abspielt ist eine
wetzel und ein drama gleichermaßen dort
sind hunderte grindwale in seichtem
wasser gestrandet die meisten von ihnen
sind verendet tierschützer versuchen
jetzt die noch 20 lebenden wale ins
tiefe wasser zu schleppen
warum immer wieder wale stranden ist
unklar wissenschaftler vermuten dass die
gruppe die orientierung verlor oder
kranken wahlen folgte so jetzt hoffe ich
dass so was erfolgreiche das heißt beim
sport katja neuigkeiten in der
bundesliga denn sowas hat es tatsächlich
noch nicht gegeben
die komplette mannschaft von mainz 05
verweigerte gestern das training nach
der suspendierung von adam szalai heute
sind sie zurück auf dem platz die wogen
sind aber alles andere als geglättet
schluss mit lustig beim selbsternannten
karnevalsverein der club hat den
32-jährigen schule offiziell nur aus
sportlichen gründen vom spiel und
trainingsbetrieb freigestellt ist es
elementar wichtig jetzt auch in der
beweggrund lage richtung adam szalai das
dementsprechend das thema szalai nichts
auch gar nichts mit dem thema gehalt zu
tun hat adam szalai soll im
mannschaftsrat darauf gepocht haben dass
von den profis während des lockouts
gestundete gehaltsanteile jetzt wie
versprochen zurückgezahlt werden
die entscheidung dass wir das wir ihnen
dann nicht mehr im training haben wollen
hat natürlich auch damit zu tun dass wir
nicht in konflikte kommen wollten der
schuss ging nach hinten los die
mannschaft bestreikte das gestrige
training aus solidarität der fsv hat
sich schon vor dem zweiten spieltag in
eine respektable krise manövriert zur
radsport wm in italien dort fand heute
rund um die formel 1 rennstrecke das
einzelzeitfahren der frauen statt und
die deutsche lisa brennauer wurde vierte
um knapp 15 sekunden verpasst die
viermalige weltmeisterin die bronze
medaille
lisa brennauer hat auf der 39 kilometer
strecke in der eu
roman ja alles gegeben die große
favoritin und titelverteidigerin kloidt
aus den usa liegt auf goldkurs als sie
die kontrolle verliert und sich so stark
verletzt dass die wm für sie beendet ist
es gewinnt die olympiasiegerin von der
regen aus den niederlanden vor der
schweizerin mal in häuser bronze alan
van dyk ebenfalls aus den niederlanden
und nochmal zum fußball heute abend
steigt der europäische supercup zwischen
bayern münchen und dem fc sevilla in
ungarns hauptstadt budapest weniger
bayern-fans als erwartet aber immerhin
noch geschätzte 1300 werden sich trotz
corona warnung auf den weg ins stadion
machen
insgesamt wurden für die partie 15.500
karten verkauft anstoß 21 uhr danke
katja bitte beim wetter kommt der regen
und gleich kommt katja horneffer mit den
details dazu
ich empfehle ihnen das heute schon mal
21 uhr 45 mit dem kollegen claus kleber
wir hier sind morgen wieder für sie da
und zwar sehr gerne für heute in allen
einen angenehmen donnerstagabend
[Musik]
meine damen und herren endlich ist der
regen da das erste tief valentina das
erreicht jetzt gerade skandinavien und
über großbritannien da kriegen sich
schon das nächste tief wie carl und so
gibt es kräftige regenfälle die breiten
sich heute nacht vom alpenrand weiter in
richtung erzgebirge aus aber auch im
westen gibt es einige regenschauer
vielleicht auch mal ein gewitter wie zb
im sauerland die nacht bleibt mild die
temperaturen sinken auf werte zwischen
14 und 7 grad morgen über tag wird es
aber kaum wärme höchstens so ein bis
drei grad zu erwarten wie es mehr wärme
geben wird 10 grad am alpenrand 17 grad
an der elbe und es schüttet ergiebig
weiter vor allen dingen den ober- und
niederbayern aber dann auch in
brandenburg und in mecklenburg
vorpommern im westen lockern die wolken
auch mal auf spätestens am nachmittag
kommen dann aber westlich des rheins und
am oberrhein neue regenschauer auf und
es fällt viel regen am alpenrand sind
das 30 bis 70 liter regen pro
quadratmeter bis morgen abend hier
nordosten nordöstlich von berlin sind
das so 20 bis 50 liter pro quadratmeter
am samstag kann es dann oberhalb von
1000 metern in den alpen schneien
der sonntag wird wechselhaft am montag
geht es an der küste mehr sonnenschein
schön haben noch